the fascinating thing that I've always
found about physics is that it studies
collections of objects and what they do
together like water can suddenly freeze
or water can boil now that's really
interesting and you think that there has
nothing to do with people other than
that people are studying it but people
are like particles people get together
on a road they form traffic jams which
is like something solidifying they get
together into groups which is very much
like particles do and so the question
arises can you ever come up with a kind
of mathematics that is like the
mathematics used for physics but
describes collections of people now
immediately there's the objection wait a
minute people have free will and people
are very different we're all very
different we're not like particles but
something interesting happens because
when we have lots of objects it doesn't
really matter that one or two or three
or all of them are individually free
well they collectively they will act
together as a group and that group has
actually some predictability 3-inch C if
I think if these coins if I flip a coin
I'll get heads or tails with 50%
probability so the chance of me flipping
say ten coins and getting ten heads is
well it's just really unlikely but when
it comes to people the chances of having
people all suddenly appear on the road
at the same time of the day and cause a
traffic jam is actually quite
predictable it's also the same with for
example stock market stock markets crash
and they rise again much quicker and
much more often than you'd expect if you
were just flipping coins and so the big
question arises is can we describe how
people act in groups say when they're
doing extreme things can we describe
that using the same kind of mathematics
and it turns out that we can
collectively people behave in quite
predictable ways and one of the things
that we've been particularly looking at
and in the last couple of years and it's
now becoming a very important topic is
how could people do that online online
people are freer they're not kind of
bound by who they live next to or who
their immediate friends are in work
they're free to explore and what you see
of a patent is very very definite
patterns appear in a way that you don't
actually see in the real world but they
happens in the online world and so the
online world where we do worry about
what people do collectively
we do worry about extreme groups that's
where the mathematics can actually be
more powerful and that's what we've been
looking at